he had a rough childhood on the Isle of
the last mile not only was life on the
Isle full of crime and poverty but you
grew up with a mom who was basically the
worst you think it's small punkin she
was never nice to you and she only used
you to achieve her personal goals you
are nothing like her you are just too
good have you ever considered that maybe
Maleficent isn't your real mom
since mal is nothing like Maleficent we
wondered who her real mother could be we
found a lot of similarities between Elsa
from frozen Anne's mouth stay tuned to
find out why we think now could possibly
be else's secret daughter stolen
princesses it wouldn't be the first time
that a princess has been stolen and
raised by a villain in Tangled mother
Gothel steals Rapunzel and raises her as
her own she wanted access to the Sun
Drop powers in Rapunzel's hair we know
all the villains seem to know each other
maybe the Lydon's took a note from
Goethals book if she knew she would be
stuck on the Isle of the Lost
Maleficent may have wanted a way out she
might have thought that the child of a
powerful Queen could help her get her
powers back
she also treats now very similar to how
Gothel treated Rapunzel she uses now and
doesn't treat her like a loving mother
would that's so different from how the
Evil Queen treats Evie she wanted Evie
to have the best life possible by
marrying a prince
Maleficent only cared for herself know
the similarities between Elsa and now if
Maleficent is a mouse real mom why is
Elsa the best candidates well they have
a lot in common let's start with the
physical similarities take a look at
Elsa and now these two have very similar
facial structures they both have big
beautiful eyes their faces don't have a
lot of sharp edges and they both have
soft undefined cheekbones they also both
have very round faces we also know from
decisions to that mouths natural hair
color is platinum blonde she goes back
to this color when she's trying to fit
in as Ben's girlfriend when she doesn't
have purple hair she looks just like
Elsa they also have a lot in common with
their personalities first of all they're
both super powerful now has such immense
power
that she can make any magical object
work from fairy godmothers wand to Hades
Ember she can also use her magic without
an object all she has to do is create a
rhyme Elsa can create whole castles and
even living creatures with her magic it
takes a lot of power to make a snow
monster we also know from the frozen two
trailer that the trolls worried Elsa's
powers were too much for this world that
makes her one of the most powerful
Disney characters ever now is definitely
the most powerful descendant they also
both master their magic really easily
mal grew up on the Isle where there was
no magic but she figured out how to use
her powers almost instantly in auradon
she's just a natural addict and Elsa is
the same way when she finally decided to
let it go she knew exactly what she was
doing she created an ice dress an ice
castle and ice monster with just a wave
of her hand that was literally the first
time she ever did anything like that and
she hadn't used her magic in years this
natural magical skill has to be genetic
it's not just their magical abilities
they have a lot in common both of them
have one person they care about more
than anyone for Elsa this person is her
sister Anna and for mal it's her best
friends easy now and Elsa has some of
the same character flaws in frozen Elsa
gets so ashamed of revealing her powers
that she runs away she was willing to
leave behind all of her responsibilities
in arendelle
she was totally overwhelmed at becoming
Queen and felt like she didn't fit in
that sounds just like mal and Dee
Simmons too she was having a hard time
fitting in Isaac and his girlfriend she
thought she was too wicked to be with
him when she found out that she was
getting engaged at the cotillion she ran
away she was willing to give up true
love and her friends
now on Elsa were both born to be Queens
Elsa is her heir to the throne being
ultra powerful made her an even better
ruler Shion raced her responsibilities
and saved arendelle from the endless
winter she is such an awesome Queen mal
is also born to be a queen if she were
really Maleficent's daughter she
wouldn't be a princess but mal craved
that ruling comes naturally to her she
will be the best Queen auradon has ever
seen sorry Belle the sign in descendants
through there is a sign that mallas
else's daughter who stained glass and
the castle features the symbol of her
puddles royal family but there are no
tangled descendants why would there be
that symbol in auradon we think this is
a sign that there is a minute lost
princess but it's not a princess from
Corona the differences from arendelle
it's a way to show that mal is destined
to be the ruler of ayodhya
because she was stolen away as a baby
now she has returns to a world where she
can be queen do you think Maleficent his
mouths natural mother or could now
belong to someone else tell us all your
Disney theories in the comments could
now from the Simmins be else's secret
daughter thanks for tuning in be sure to
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to click Subscribe we'll
see you next time
[Music]